[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
endgame class as always my name is caleb
denby
and today i want to take you through
some really exciting endgames
uh played by timor rajabov your 2021
air things masters uh champion uh this
i think is leg two of the champions
chess tour
that chess 24 is hosting and rajbov is
definitely not
who many people had picked to win the
event at the start of course as i said
in the road to 2000 tonight
uh world champion magnus carlson and
online tournament
favorites like ikaru nakamura and wesley
so were actually eliminated
in the first round of knockouts leaving
players like rajabov aronian
dubov mvl some time to shine
so let's take a look at some of those
end games i want to start with a game
played between rajabov and irony i
believe in those finals
and i'm going to do something very very
unusual for this class
which is show you almost the entire game
because
despite it being an endgame class i
think there were some interesting
decisions
made early on that did impact the
resulting end game so let's take a look
we have the opening which i'm not going
to spend much time on
it was a grunfeld with an early bishop
g5 knight e4 line
and here we see these pawns getting
doubled ce3
knight c6 and white undoubling those
pawns pretty swiftly
and here already we are going to see
pieces disappearing from the board
with queen f3 queen d7 bishop b5
a6 and now bishop takes c6 queen takes
c6 queen takes c6
and pawn takes c6 and well you might
claim we are not yet in an endgame
we are sort of rapidly approaching this
uh
that that distinction as many many
pieces have disappeared
from the board so what kind of end game
is it going to be
is still sort of up for grabs we do see
for the moment
that white is going to have the superior
structure
and that is going to be a definite
advantage but
in response for the moment black at
least has the bishop pair
and has a lot of flexibility with the
structure it may not actually be as bad
as you would first expect by the way
because these pawns are often going to
have the opportunity
to trade one of them off for this
d4 pawn so that's just where we stand i
do want to go a little bit further
before we get into serious thought we
have knight f3 bishop g7
knight e5 now and bishop f5
by aronian and you can see now this idea
of having a structural deficit in
exchange for a dynamic advantage like
the two bishops
is being used by aronian here for
example
white may not yet be ready to do
something like knight takes on c6
in light of moves like cd4 cd4 and
bishop e4
when the power of these bishops is
beginning to
come to light here so instead we do see
f3 perhaps with this exact idea in mind
and now we do in fact see aronian ready
to capture on e5 and this was a pretty
interesting decision
by ironian i think it was an attempt at
equalizing rather than playing for any
kind of advantage
and we'll see how it goes for him so we
have bishop takes e5 f6
and bishop g3 and the idea for levon
ironian was to plant this bishop on d3
and further cement it with a pawn on c4
so i would like to pause here
as i am willing to call this an end game
of sorts it's not the classical end game
with only one piece for either side but
we do just have
one minor piece and the two rooks so
what is going on in this endgame
who should be happy and what should both
sides
be aiming to do
oh this must be the f6 mistake by
aronian
i wouldn't say f6 was the key mistake
here
if you play the move bishop takes e5 you
should really be continuing with the
move
f6 in this position i think that just
makes sense you can argue that bishop
takes e5 was the mistake
but f6 i don't think is
a game loser so yeah chess king says
white has a good pawn structure uh
and yes that that's true white has a
good pawn structure i
am going to argue though that that is
not the most
relevant factor at hand uh in this
position
chess king says white has a good
structure so he should be winning in
king and pawn end games that's great
but unfortunately there are six other
pieces on the board
so jacob is touching on the right idea
but perhaps
for the wrong side uh what this game
is all about is not even this
necessarily this pawn structure yet
it's true that this pawn structure is
going to be one source of some advantage
for white
but much more importantly than that it's
down to the only open file
on the board in middle games and end
games alike when there's only one open
file on the board and rooks are on the
board
then whoever can control that file is
almost invariably going to be the side
with the advantage
and in this case white does have a path
to control this file
so chat room what should white's next
three moves be
in order to gain control of this file in
season advantage
king rob says another chess tournament
how many tournaments do they play this
year
or per year and quite a bit
i think they are playing a lot more
online tournaments one after the other
because
the fact that they no longer have to
travel for chess tournaments is allowing
them to play more of them
okay so there's a few ideas but uh
actually somewhat surprisingly nobody
has found the the correct idea played in
the game
uh this is actually a moment when
urgency is is very much called for so
jacob was saying
that the b file actually favors black
because black can play rook a7 and or b7
whereas white cannot and that would be
true if white tries this idea of
something like a4 rook a2 rook b2
i think black would be very you know
very well off by countering this idea by
occupying the b file first
so ideas like this are simply too slow
and ideas like
king to d2 with bishop f5 and e4 this
would be great
but black's idea of bishop d3 is to
cement this piece here
with the move pawn to e4 so of course or
not e4 pawn to c4 so of course what
white should do is what rajab does in
the game noticing
the urgency of controlling this b file
he plays rook d1 with tempo
forcing the move c4 by black and now
rook d2 to b2
without hesitation and it is in fact
going to be white who arrives at the b
file first now now that white
is taking over control of the b file
this weakness and pawn structure can
start to become a lot more relevant
than it otherwise would be right you can
imagine for example
a rook landing on b6 could be
devastating for black
whereas in a position like this just to
highlight this again
let's say something like king f2 you
could really make a case
for black being being much better in
this position because black has
gained control over this only open file
on the board
how are you ever going to attack these
pawns if black controls the only open
file
you simply cannot so b file of the
utmost
importance and this is a a feature that
really does sort of transcend this
specific position
whenever there is only one open file on
the board uh normally in middle games
but especially in
end games with rooks on the board it is
very very important to gain control of
that file or at least be able to contest
that file because that is the path to
activity
so rook d1 rook d2 and king f7 by black
and roger does continue now with rook to
b2 and this is
uh perfect this is correct levon ironian
continues now with rook
h to d8 trying to find activity and
rajabov continues out with e4
sort of taking things slowly moves like
king f2 and king d2 or perhaps
maybe even a little bit more natural
allowing this rook access to the game
but e4 is just as good taking control of
the center
and notably perhaps giving this king
some other squares
perhaps aiming for squares in this
manner as well
and now levon aronian uh perhaps despite
you know the the appearance
of you know a boring simple end game i
get the feeling lavonne was feeling a
little bit
under pressure in this position and due
to that pressure he actually already
makes a a pretty serious mistake here so
i want to ask the chatroom
what you think what you think
should be played here for levon iranian
what should black
do take a second to go ahead and think
about it
uh okay so i am now going to reveal the
answer
in the game lavon had placed this rook
onto d8
to attack along the d file and his idea
to follow this up
was c5 aiming to break down these pawns
and activate the
the rook uh unfortunately for him this
was simply
wrong this is in fact a pawn sacrifice
raj bob
accepted the free pawn and then had an
extra pawn
and this is of course going to be an
advantage uh
instead lavonne probably should have
played the slightly strange looking move
rook d7 and i think this goes a long way
towards highlighting the just sort of
overpowering
importance of the b file the idea of
rook to d7
is to go rook to a7 rook a to a7
and rook a to b7 that that is how
important
the b file is here black should be even
playing these this incredibly awkward
looking maneuver
in order to try and take control of the
b-file
and similarly an equally ridiculous
looking move
by white should probably be played in
response in the form of bishop b8
just saying no don't play rook a7 i'm
controlling
this b-file and then of course we might
see
a bit of a repetition here and
now white can perhaps slightly improve
the bishop
and at the end of the day black is is
probably going to be getting
the b file back that that is the point
i'm trying to get across here black is
going to go for moves like rook a to a7
and rook to b7
and perhaps after this black is still
going to be in the game
instead though levon goes for c5 and
this idea i do think is just flawed
after the move d takes c5
uh also uh while we figured this out
i was using my phone to look at the chat
and it died
devastating so i'm actually going to
pull up open a chat really quick here
maybe
ben can cut away from the board for a
second ben
benjamin ben simon maybe not okay
we will press on until then here's my
please
okay rookie c8 played in the game and
i'm just not going to be able to
to look at the chat for for a few
moments here okay rook a to c8
challenging this pawn on c5 and of
course here the idea
is going to be bishop f2 simply
maintaining this extra pawn
and so from here the dynamic of the game
is is going to change pretty
considerably
now rather than have the b file in the
better structure
rajbov has the b file and the extra pawn
and that is simply going to be enough
for an almost winning
advantage opposite colored bishops or
not
so i do think levon aronian does a
pretty good job here
of putting up a fight so in this
position i'd like you guys at home
to try and think for a second about how
exactly you can try and create some
complications for white to deal with
in the meantime i am going to do my best
to pull open a chat here
as i sneakily do things
ah and ben has switched it okay i think
you can go back to the board button
because
i've done all i need to do beautiful
so how can black create some intrigue
here
okay get the rook into the game
okay and everybody in the chat is having
some some pretty good ideas here
so in fact yes i do like this move f5
from a practical perspective
by lefonronian it's easy to say you know
try to get the rook into the game
but f5 is a very nice concrete idea to
try and achieve this purpose
you want to open files up find activity
because if you can't control the b
file you better make sure that you are
able to access another file on the board
or else you're just doomed to passivity
and you're going to let
white circle sort of walk all over you
what i don't think you want to do
in this case is do something like e5
allowing simple improving moves like
bishop e3 and king f2 for example
when white is going to be able to enter
the game with the second rook and
after this you're simply upon down and
ideas like rook b6 checker are coming as
well
probably shouldn't have played king e6
let's say rook c6 for example
king f2 and white once again
is entering the game with the last
stroke black has not done enough here
to create problems so f5 by levon
aronian
is correct and should be played
immediately in my opinion just half
to make things more interesting we do
see e takes f5
by white but now g takes f5 by black
and not only does black potentially have
an open file to try and
create some pressure on but also ideas
of pushing down the center of the board
as well with this e pawn okay
we continue now with bishop e3 which is
very natural move you need the ef2
square for the king
and to get this rook in h1 into the game
uh but now we do see levon aronian has
another idea up his sleeve in the form
of
f4 drawing this bishop away from the
defense of c5
so bishop takes f4 bishop c5 played now
king f2
and finally you know black has achieved
the all-time goal of stopping white
from having total dominance over the b
file unfortunately for black
now this has come at the cost of a full
pawn
right levon had this idea of c5 to find
activity and it worked to some extent
but it did cost a pawn so of course
black is going to be worse but
again if there's one thing you take away
from this end game here
it should be this idea of the you know
supreme importance
of having control of the only open file
on the board
and for that reason levon aronian was
ready to part
with one of his c pawns just to stop
white from having this
okay we see rook takes b5 in the game a
takes b5
and then a very interesting move here by
rajab
is a3 so
this is another really instructive move
in this end game that i'm
excited to talk about because i'm a big
endgame nerd
so a2 to a3 i don't think is a move that
would be
on too many people's minds here and this
goes to show
the the second really really important
idea
uh in really any end game but especially
in games like this
with uh one rook and one minor piece and
that idea
is the the power of having a past pawn
so what's the point of a3 why was a3
played
directly in fact it didn't really need
to be played directly
but the point is simply that if you
start taking your time doing other
things
eventually a move like b4 is is going to
be good for black
i'm not saying it's good immediately in
fact it's probably quite bad immediately
but eventually later on an idea like b4
is going to allow black to create a past
pawn at any moment
and this is a threat that you simply
don't want to
allow there's simply no reason to to
allow this threat
to sort of exist in the position
i think there was also a secondary idea
for doing
doing it immediately and that is the
fact that you want to control
the a3 square and for for those of you
who have played a game
like go this should be an idea that
you're very familiar with
right control of territory but in chess
you know you might not think that the
best way to to control a square
is is to put a pawn onto it in this case
we
are having better control of territory
behind our pawns
rather than territory in front of our
pawns so by drawing a3
to be in a position behind our pawns we
do control that square a little bit
better
as evidenced by the next moves rook a8
rook a1
now let's compare this if something like
g4 were to be played instead
now if rook a8 rook a1 all of a sudden
we don't control the a3 square
and black is able to to occupy
occupy it and have a very very active
rook
now this wouldn't be sort of fatal to
white's position or anything white is
still up a pawn and can defend quite
naturally with bishop e5
but it's really cool to note this
inclusion of the move a3
both as a territory gaining move just to
bring
a3 into the folds of the white camp
and also as a preventative move
preventing this pawn on b5 from ever
stepping to b4
so rookie 8 rook a1 played in the game
and
aronian sort of passes the time with the
move rick a6
maybe activating the rook somewhat
allowing it access
to squares like e6 and h6 in
perhaps d6 for whatever reason but
sort of just passing the time back to uh
to white
now is the question for now it's a
question for for rajabov you have done a
good job
of preemptively preventing uh your
opponent from getting any activity
on the queen side here or too much
activity on the queen's side
now how do you actually go about the
business of pressing
for the win in this game what should be
step number one
chat what should we do
uh nicholas asks would bishop d2 be just
as good as e5 to protect the pawn
uh i would prefer uh e5 uh somewhat i
think
mainly because if you can imagine that
position it might make more sense to
eventually defend this pawn with the
king and have an active bishop
but bishop d2 was was perfectly fine as
far as which one
i would prefer i would probably prefer
bishop b5 but i don't think it matters a
great deal
so in this case i think elvis actually
has the right
idea in the chat so
uh in pure rook and games or pure minor
peace and games king activity is
definitely
a priority numer numer i can't speak
priority
number one numero uno is what i was
trying to say
but in end games with uh two pieces on
the board
things do change i think somewhat uh
why is that well because your opponent
has a little bit more freedom to
to move around and poke at your weak
pawns so in this case
the white king is actually doing a good
job defending some weaknesses in the
white camp
if you start going crazy playing things
like king e3 king d4
you might find yourself with a lack of
defenders around these pawns on the
king's side
compare this with where the king is now
if this idea were to be tried we could
immediately start finding counter play
with something like
a4 or something like rookie one even
just to
to combat our opponent's rooks for
example let's say something like h3 or
k6 were played
then even rook a2 the idea of rick b2
could be played bishop b3 is fine rookie
one is fine
all these moves are perfectly fine
although okay i should say rookie one is
probably not great because you don't
want the pure opposite color bishop end
game uh that that should be clear to
many people but
don't know why i kept saying rookie one
but yeah rook a2 i think is quite good
or even bishop e3 when again this king
does a great job
of defending weaknesses so instead we
see g4 and elvis's idea in the chat
wants to push the king side pawns and
that is going to be correct in this
in this case you just want to gain some
extra space
and start introducing the threat of
creating a past pawn on the king's side
of the board
so roger bob takes it slow he's not in a
rush just plays g4
takes a little bit of extra space no
need to rush the king up the board just
yet the king is serving a useful purpose
on f2
we see levon aronian playing the move
king e6 and now h4
king d5 h5 by uh
white uh e5 now is levon aronian's
uh idea we see bishop e3 rook a8
and now we start passing a little bit
some
passing of the time here we see this
move
uh this bishop being rerouted to be able
to apply some pressure to the pawn on e5
and now that the pawns have been pushed
up a little bit and the
e file has been closed we do actually
see king e3 by rajab as well
king e6 and rook a2 giving the rook a
little bit more mobility king d5 bishop
e7 and the passes sort of continue here
with rajabov slowly but surely
improving his pieces to sort of their
optimal position
all the pawns are on light squares to
allow them some mobility
despite the light squared bishop on the
enemy side of the board
then this bishop has been routed to uh
the nice defensive square on b4
where it can control the a3 pawn freeing
up the rook
the king has been centralized and pushed
up as far as it can while still
defending the weak pawns
and so now it's it's sort of go time for
white that being said in this position
i still wasn't quite sure uh what the
plan
for improvement actually was with the
white pieces here
i just i didn't didn't really see it
i thought black should probably just
play a move like king
to d5 and start passing the time right
you know
it's white's job to try and break
through here and a lot of times the best
defensive technique
is sort of sitting on your position and
not doing much it's sort of one
that's very very difficult for these top
players to do often times they want to
do
things sort of proactively find activity
find counter play
but sometimes the best thing to do is is
nothing and i think that's the case here
because what is white going to do
white can try and pressure this pawn a
little bit but even king c6 for example
just
puts a stop to that quite quickly and
how else is white going to make progress
uh let's say something like
uh let's say king king to c6 is played
and white tries to move f4
sure now we can take on f4 and the the
question sort of arises again
how how is white actually going to make
any progress if you play g6
sure i'll take that one as well and
it's not clear how white's going to make
a past pawn it's not clear how white
it's going to make progress
so i thought lavon probably should have
just sat on the position instead he
makes
what is probably the the worst move of
the game in my opinion
which is h6 i just simply don't
understand this move
and i think the chat should probably
have a similar view to me
and probably understand what's what's
wrong with it
pretty immediately so in end games
with bishops of opposite colors we did
see white
putting all of his pawns on light
squares but this was with the point of
allowing some mobility for these pawns
right
the pawns wanted to to push forward and
in order to do that you need
the pawns help to control the light
squares that your opponent has a good
grip on
now in the other circumstance this pawn
of course doesn't have
any mobility and by putting it on this
dark square
all you have really achieved is giving
your opponent a target
for this dark squared bishop now it's
not immediately obvious
how white is supposed to attack the h6
pawn with this bishop on b4
but it doesn't have to be immediately
obvious and we see that white very
slowly and methodically
just brings this bishop to e3 attacks
the pawn on h6
and black is sort of left defenseless
there's simply nothing to do here
so h6 i think this is probably the the
flat out losing move for levon aronian
perhaps white could have come up with a
winning plan if
levon had sat on the position but here
h6 definitely
makes the task much much easier the game
continued with rook b2
we saw bishop h7 by lavonne now just
passing time
but now king f2 bishop d3
bishop c5 and just like that you know
the the time is now
there's no way to defend against bishop
e3
and bishop h6 king d5 was played in the
game
now bishop d3 rook takes a3 wouldn't be
doing enough
after it takes b5 check king d6 for
example
bc rook b6 check king d5 for example
and rook takes h6 it's true that you
would get to take
on c3 but now white's pawns are simply
coming more quickly
and more devastatingly right if this
pawn gets to c1
white takes it if this pawn gets to g8
it's a lot harder for black to sacrifice
a piece for it
so white would simply be winning instead
we saw king c6
by aronian trying to hold on to the b5
pawn
but now simply rook a2 rajab doesn't
really give any ground here
and says i'm just going to defend my
pawn good luck defending yours
rook to h8 could have been played to try
and hold on to the pawn
but at this point again we see the
importance of an open file
as white is able to open open things up
and
invade with the rook and again just just
win the game
the game continued with e4 which was
sort of a last ditch effort but simply
bishop takes h6 and now these pawns are
connected
and passed this game is is just over
we do see this before idea and there is
some complication left
but if worst comes to worst what white
can sacrifice the bishop for this pawn
and black is just not going to be able
to stop these pawns on both sides of the
board
we see a4 a5 the bishop comes back to c1
now a6 and after a repetition
white to move and win is pretty easy
here if you guys want to take a moment
to try to find it
of course the correct move is simply a7
what's the point the point is that after
rook takes age six
we make a queen they make a queen but
white is actually able
to win black's queen immediately with
rook takes b1
and this was the last move of the game
before levon aronian
resigned so really interesting end game
play
that i wanted to highlight here again
the really really key points i wanted to
mention
were this idea of controlling the only
open file on the board i think
rajabov's best sequence of moves in this
game
may have been this rook d1 rook d2
rook b2 you just absolutely have to
control this file
as quickly as possible then we saw a
lavonronian
trying to make the situation a little
bit more complex
by pushing some pawns forward and
opening files for himself eventually
sacrificing a pawn
but at the end of the day h6 is just a
pretty bad
pretty bad move by lavon that allows
rajabov this easy winning plan
of just targeting this pawn so questions
on this endgame before we move on
to a second one questions on this end
game
sending is a repeat from past episode i
really don't think that's the case
because this was played in 2021
and this is the first endgame class of
2021. so that
i don't know doesn't seem likely it
doesn't seem likely
oh no unless maybe it is a repeat if uh
if like mercia did it or something i
didn't check what mercy was covering
this week
tough all right
the whole game was theory says manny not
quite not quite
was it not possible for white to put the
bishop on d4 and the king on e4 locking
up the center
i don't believe so i think we had this
this pawn on e5 right
right black was always going to be able
to achieve pawn to e5
so you can never really cement this
bishop on d4 comfortably like that that
bishop is never really going to
have a permanent home there like let's
say
you go bishop b5 here bishop d4 king e3
already you're getting you're getting
hit with with e5
and in fact the bishop is trapped in
this case which would not be ideal
good question though good question
when levon played c5 was it a good move
to play f5
and then yeah we'll go over this this b
file idea one more time but yeah lavon
playing
c5 uh okay f5 instead so yeah i think f5
might have been
a better try the the problem is that
uh black really is running out of time
to find active play so
white would likely take on f5 you can
try g takes f5 as
as in the game but now after king f2
uh playing f5 may have actually helped
white's chances
by by opening up this e file and you
might be
forced to to pretty immediately play
something like like c5 anyways
because if you're going to play f5
opening up the center like this you
probably also want to be gaining control
over the e5 square or else things could
be tough so something like rook
to d5 and perhaps this was a slower more
controlled way of trying to open things
up
but it comes at the risk of allowing
white
exactly what was mentioned in the
previous comment with ideas of bishop d4
when e5 is harder to achieve when black
white now has control
of a very very relevant half open file
and still
the only truly open file the d file is
technically open but not really usable
but yeah that's a good question as well
and then one more time let's look at the
difference here we see
rajab playing rook d1 with tempo rook d2
not allowing black time to get into the
b file
when after rook b2 rook d8 we see e4
and again i think black's best idea is
to
really sort of brute force try and find
your way
to the b7 square whereas if you play
something like a4
i do think black is truly on the better
side of things
after rook b7 black controls the b file
now it's going to be white who is
scrambling to get the forces in order
here
and i think black is is better i think
black is just better in this case for
example something like c4 rook d1 we can
even play
king f7 rook d2 trying to gain control
but
uh it's it's all coming very very slowly
as black is getting
the all the active play okay
so good questions let's move on to one
more we are running a bit low on time
so i do want to get to at least one more
complete end game
they might be saying that this game
resembles the game that aronian beat
nakamura as black
i don't know maybe they did have
opposite colored bishops but let us
continue along
to another endgame to another endgame
not this one
not this one not this one this one this
is the one i want to do
and i want to do this one because it's
an ordinary
game it's so boring they played like
grand masters
and then agreed to a draw and these are
the games
that never get covered if you want to
watch like agonator that's great
but he never covers games like these i
never cover games like these
and so i wanted to take a look at what
is actually
you know somewhat interesting in the
form of a boring
grandmaster draw not a grandmaster draw
where they agreed to a draw on move 15
but a grand master draw where they both
played chess almost perfectly
and then because they played well the
the game was drawn
right i think there's actually a lot to
talk about in these games
and a lot to uh to think about so let's
take a look we're going to
look from the point of view of rajabov
as he had the black pieces in this game
and i think when this was played he
might have also had an advantage in the
match and was sort of trying to uh
to calm things down a bit uh and yeah
here we go so we have the opening which
nobody cares about
um and then we have the middle game
which nobody cares about what are we
doing
at g5 that looks like fun this doesn't
this is not an endgame
not an endgame not an end game nowhere
near an endgame
not ready to talk about this yet oh my
god way too interesting
way too many things going on oh pieces
are being traded
pieces are being traded okay let's let's
get a few more pieces off the board
take take take
take all right i think we officially
have ourselves an
end game so of course this position
is approximately equal why is it
approximately equal because
both sides have even material both sides
have a rook both sides have a knight
and there there's not too much uh going
on
in the way of activity differences no
no side really has the more active
pieces just yet and there's not too much
going on
in in the pawn structure either that
being said if you gave levon oroni in
this position
against i think maybe even some some
strong 2400s maybe even 2500s
i think lavonne might be able to to pull
out a win
uh on occasion so let's see what's going
on here
definitely there's chess left to be
played in this game
but as you see the the game does end in
a draw
and i think both sides did a pretty good
job of getting there
so let's actually take a look from levon
aronian's perspective
you are trying to come back in the match
you're trying to win
win a game or two and perhaps you have a
slight
slight practical advantage because
number one it's your turn number two
these pawns
are all slightly weak and you know
number three
there is no number three those are your
only two real real advantages
so what can you do to to try and keep
the game going here try and keep things
interesting what do you think chat
let's play some practical chess rook d7
to b7 okay
so rook d7 to b7 is a good idea
anything else that comes to mind here
anything else i will tell you that rook
d7 to b7 is not
what was played in this chess game
so clearly other ideas exist
h4h5 but you prefer the rook moves you
do not like white's king it's very
passive smash the weak pawns to bits
so let's look at rook d7 uh to b7 first
so um the person whose name i cannot
read uh
was correct in saying that that h4h5 is
a pretty good idea
uh or or is an idea he didn't like it
very much but
but it is an idea and this is actually
what levon goes for in the game
and i'm actually quite happy with this
decision
for one i think it's very easy to
imagine a
uh lesser chess player than team rajabov
going for something active like rook a4
it's very easy to sort of fall into this
trap where you're like why don't i just
attack this b-pawn
what is this guy doing even if you
calculate a little bit
at first glance it may not be apparent
that this is all that good for white
however this is definitely an advantage
for white and the reason is this knight
is entirely hemmed in on
f8 white can cement the pawn structure
with pawn to f3
and while this pawn is passed it is
definitely not strong
white is going to be able to try and
target this pawn with ideas like rook d6
to b6 and take advantage of the fact
that this knight is for the moment
locked out of the game white in fact
may actually be close to winning in this
position i'm not going to say that white
is winning but white is definitely a lot
better so
h4 is a really really sneaky little move
by levon aronian here and this is what
these super gm's do
is they play a move that gives you
options
that is the way to to win in a lot of
equal end games
uh you know the the saying goes you have
to give your opponent
you know enough rope to tie themself up
tie themselves up in knots right that's
that's what they say
uh okay so h4 allows black to make a
decision
and that is how like i said one more
time that is how strong players win
in equal end games they allow their
opponent uh enough room to make some
decisions
and to make the wrong decisions now that
being said team rajabov
is good enough to not make the wrong
decisions
so h4 let's look at another slight
mistake that black may have fallen into
black may notice this line with rook
a4 attacking b4 is not good and they
might say well why don't i just stop h5
and play h5 myself but this is actually
another
small victory for black it's it's not
the huge mistake
that uh that rook a4 is but h5 is
definitely
you know at least a moral win for white
because you're advancing this pawn
further up the board
making it slightly more weak and further
highlighting the fact that black is
missing the g
pawn black is not able to defend this
pawn with another pawn
so stuff like rook d7 rek h7 does start
to become
a very legitimate threat that black has
to worry about
but of course rajabov makes none of
these mistakes and
corrected correctly plays the move king
f6 which simply
defends the pawn on f6 and allows black
the e7 square for the knight and also
allows black to sort of refute any rook
d7 ideas
by keeping this rank close there's no
rook d7 rook h7 to worry about anymore
with all that being said i do want to
look at rook d7 check as well
compared to the previous move this
allows black a lot less room for
error it makes black's play sort of
rather forcing
you don't really want to go to the back
rank with the king you want to keep the
king active so king f6 is sort of the
only move
now let's say you play the move rook b7
well black says well gosh my my pawns
attacked i i have to do something rather
immediately
so they play rook a1 check king goes to
h2
and they go rook f1 because what else
are they going to do or rook a2 well
really either either of these moves are
perfectly fine but let's say rook f1
just just to highlight the fact that
your king is stuck
here okay so you get to take on b5 but
now they get to take on f2
and you start to get the feeling that
white may not be playing for the win
anymore
black is going to get the rook behind
the past pawn
and white's king is definitely the one
with a little bit less safety
it's pretty easy to imagine here that
this knight gets a little bit tied down
to defending the king has to stop the
idea of knight h4
black's king runs a little bit over to
the queen side
and before you know it maybe the b pawn
falls maybe the e pawn falls maybe black
wins the game
right this is not the type of entry that
you really want with the white pieces
and it's all very forcing you sort of
force your opponent down a path like
this
by playing these moves there's very
little that you can actually do
to aside from these these active lines
for black
so rook d7 to b7 definitely not the way
to go i spent a lot of time talking
about it now but
i really do like this move h4 allowing
black to make a decision allowing some
room for him to make the wrong decision
roger bob though talented chess player
good chess player plays king of six
we see h5 and now 97
finally we do see white uh trying to
invade with the rook but of course we've
seen
that even when it was with check this
idea was not all that strong
rook a4 comes by rajabov once again
rick d7 now sort of forcing black to
play the active
uh active option forcing black to play
the best moves
but at this point there was little else
that really could be done
for levon aronian now the reason why
white isn't any worse here is because
there is a nice little tactic of knight
takes e5
we see king takes e5 rook takes c7
king back to f6 forcing the rook back to
e8
and now rook takes on b4
so we have a couple key differences from
a similar variation
that i looked at where black played rook
a4 immediately after h4
one key difference is that the knights
are off the board
which actually does make a huge
difference compared to that position
when black's knight was stuck on f8
and secondly black's king is a little
bit more free to move around
and white is unfortunately dealing with
a slightly overextended
h5 pawn as well this push sort of did
not come
for free there there was a bit of a cost
to it uh that being said though
four pawns versus four still should just
really be a draw
without too much trouble for these top
level players
levon starts with a very solidifying
move of f3
we see rook b2 by black keeping the king
shut out on the first rank but now king
h2
does find some activity b4
by black and now i would like you to try
and draw the game
for levon aronian i think it's safe to
say that the time
when lavonne was aiming to win the game
has pretty much
passed but a couple more accurate moves
could be required
before we can safely say white has no
danger at all here
so chet wait to move how do you want to
treat this position
oliver gill says uh why rookie eight so
i'll talk about that
so yeah you guys are are finding the the
actu the the two moves that lavon didn't
play
but the the two moves that are also fine
um
so for those of you saying rook h8 uh
you're saying king g7 and then rook b8
but let me ask you about king g5
because it's very important to realize
that king g5 is legal
right i talked about this weakness on h5
and you do have to be ready
to deal with it and same question for
the people saying rick b8 what are you
doing about king g5
what are you doing about king g5 if you
give this check
what are you doing about king h4 right
all of a sudden one wrong step and your
king is stuck on h2 you might lose the
game
might lose the game
so for these reasons uh i like steve
north's moves
the the best here uh king g5 why not
rook b6
so yeah this is the story uh
unfortunately for black
if black were trying to win the game
moves like rook b6 uh
are going to be enough to sort of hold
the game to a draw
because uh black is really not getting
anywhere
by losing this this e pawn as well
but it's worth noting that these type
these types of tactical solutions
are not always you know readily
available or readily apparent right when
you're relying on
ideas like this from afar sometimes you
know something gets missed
along the way some sneaky mate threat
some sneaky b3 push
and next thing you know you're having
some issues for example
after king f6 let's say you pass the
time
and you allow b3 and you pass the time
rook b1 and you pass the time now all of
a sudden
after king g5 you actually are quite
close to losing
you are significantly worse off here
with white compared to
where you were a few moments ago so for
those reasons
the drawing setup for levon aronian is
the one that he plays in the game
with king h3 first it's just a really
nice subtlety
highlighting the fact that this king is
needed to control the squares of h4 and
g4
so that after king g5 we can actually
safely play rook b5 check
and be controlling simply everything so
king h3 was the key idea that i was
hoping you guys
might look out for keeping in mind that
we do need to be wary
of our h5 pawn so king h3 played in the
game by the monaronian
that being said rook h8 and rook b8 both
enough to draw
keeping in mind uh threats against e6
but also keeping in mind that that is
not good enough to draw forever
because this pawn is going to advance uh
all right
all that in mind king h3 b3 played now
rook b8s
king e5 and we do see just rook b6 here
keeping the kingpin down
if we saw king g5 there's no doubt in my
mind that levon ironian was intending
rook b5 check
when the scary looking king h4 is is no
longer available
in the game is rapidly heading towards a
draw
so we see rook b8 uh king e5 rook b6
rook b1
now king g4 looking to trade off the
remainder of the king side pawns
uh and eventually now rook g1 rook b5
check king d4
rook takes b3 rook takes g2 king takes
f4
rook up to g5 and the game
does fizzle out now as we have two pawns
versus two
and eventually one pawn versus one no
pawns versus none
and king versus king and draw
is um not not agreed
just by the rules of chess draw
so that is the the end game i wanted to
show you like i said not a lot of
controversy in this end game both
players just played it very well
but there were a couple key moments and
a couple key decisions that
were really really important to
understand because if
if either player were to go a little bit
wrong in this game
we would be looking at a wildly
different result
so any questions on this end game before
we call today here and head
on over to twitch
draw by insufficient material that that
is the
phrase that escaped my mind why is it
losing if the black king gets to h4
okay i will look at this briefly these
end games do tend to be
really really complicated but let's talk
about
what happens if let's say just some some
very bad moves are played
rook b5 check rather king h4
and yeah what let's say uh
i i don't know it's it's difficult to
suggest a pass here
like let's say
uh rook let's say you know black had an
extra tempo
right an extra tempo now why is this
losing well black is going to play rook
b1
you have to play a move this king cannot
move
you can move this pawn to e5 if you want
but black is going to play a move
now you have to move again and then
black's going to be able to take on h5
you simply are left with no legal moves
and because of that
you have to play a bad move and then
you're going to lose the game so like
rook
v6 for example b2 you can't even take
here anymore
because work h1 and b1 queen so with the
king on h4 you simply get stalemated and
forced into
a zig zong but good question good
question
uh why isn't white worried about mating
ideas uh after king h3 i assume
so it's not really ever a problem
because whenever black plays king g5
he's the whole point of having the king
on well sorry
uh let's say b3 the whole point of
having the king on h3
is that we can meet king g5 with with
rook b5 check so it's it's never
actually going to be checkmate the king
will always have the g4 square
all right with those questions i am
actually going to call it here
uh as we wrap up this endgame class if
you're watching live i would say
now is the time to head over to twitch
you want to get there early
for analyze your games because the
number of games i can analyze
is very finite and the number of people
wanting them analyzed
continues to grow every week which i'm
thankful for but unfortunately that
means that i do have to stop accepting
submissions
fairly early so head over to analyze
your games on twitch
right now twitch.tv stl chess club
that is going to do it for us here
tonight on youtube as always
my name is caleb denby and thank you so
much
for watching
[Music]
you